hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers in game
truly marked the end of this game of
Marvel's 11 year infinity saga including
the biggest shocker of all no
post-credit scene they had us sitting
through ten minutes of scrolling names
for what recognize the thousands of VFX
artists who make these movies so
visually stunning nah give me that tease
but as many of us at and sob through
these credits he may have noticed a
little post-credits moment an
interesting sound effect spoiler warning
if you haven't seen any game yet the
pings of a hammer on an anvil check it
out this is the exact sound of Tony
Stark in the Afghan cave of the first
Iron Man film hammering his first
armored suit from a box of scraps in
order to escape Avengers have gained in
many ways saw Tony Stark coming full
circle with his origin in the series the
shot of him engineering on the Benatar
ship with box of scraps nebula directly
evoked his time in the cave his message
to pepper to not post this on social
media called back him telling the
soldiers not to post their photo on
their MySpace page and just as he told
them he wanted peace he says the same
thing to cap an end game and his funeral
wreath includes his proof Tony Stark has
a heart arc reactor that pepper gave him
an iron man and his daughter Morgan once
happy to get her cheeseburgers just like
Tony wanted to get right after escaping
actually check out our full movie
Avengers endgame breakdowns for more
details and callbacks like that but this
post-credit audio seems like a similar
kind of callback a coda to where this
journey began with a too clever for his
own good engineer cobbling together
something that he wasn't even supposed
to build which would later grow into
this massive game-changing universe the
directors Arusha brothers said it wasn't
their doing to include this they
confirmed it actually came from the top
Marvel head Kevin Feige himself so
knowing this could fika have been
hinting at something more with this
sound effect Tony Stark may be dead but
his legacy is playing a very important
role in these post in-game times perhaps
the sound of Iron Man armor being
hammered together suggests a new
generation of Avengers being assembled
for example the recent spider-man far
from home trailers suggests that movie
will very much focus on the question of
who carries the torch in iron man's
absence with Peter Parker Tony Stark's
son
figure in past MCU films now up against
figures like Quentin Beck whose
technology seems very inspired by Starks
armor in repulsors Tony starts decisions
throughout in game in retrospect were
largely driven by Peter Parker looking
at a photo of Peter led Tony to give the
time heist a second chance if he gave
Peter that meaningful hug during the
final battle the far from home trailer
also features Peter Waring Tony Stark
sunglasses from infinity war an endgame
sunglasses with special heads-up
displays in which Tony could have hidden
a secret recording of himself to Peter
like the one he left for pepper and
Morgan at the end of endgame my dream
scenario is that Robert Downey jr.
continues to return and Tony Stark
cameos like this like maybe Stark
recorded hundreds of little messages to
inspire his loved ones and tantas
buddies like post mortem Tony Stark
workout video for Thor to lose that
melted ice cream gut p3000 axe so maybe
this hammer audio is meant for us to
look ahead to the next Ironman that end
game was setting up spider-man and how
far from home will show him literally
and metaphorically rebuilding and
refilling Tony Stark's armor but Peter
Parker isn't the only Avenger operating
Stark's tech of course there's Rhodey
war machine who showed up in the final
battle with a new suit that he found in
the rubble of Avengers HQ and Pepper
Potts wearing a new suit inspired by the
rescue armor in the comics earlier in
the film Tony and peppers daughter
Morgan wore that same helmet she found
it in the garage could Morgan one day
carry on her father's legacy
we just learned about a deleted
alternate ending scene with Tony after
his snap visiting that same orangie
realm that Thanos did after his snap and
infinity war and like Thanos meeting
Gamora Tony would have met his daughter
Morgan but grown up played by actress
Catherine Langford that scene was
deleted from the film but Kevin Feige
could be keeping her in mind for a
future incarnation of Iron Man and that
hammering sound was meant not only as a
callback but as a hint from Marvel to
say don't worry we're back in the
workshop and Iron Man will live on
comment down below with what you think
this post credit hammering sound means
and follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at ei vas subscribe to new rockstars on
YouTube and follow our new podcast feed
inside marvel for early access to all of
our Marvel coverage thanks for joining
me and
awesome neighbor who's always
re-enacting Tony Stark's armour
hammering at 6:00 in the damn morning
please stop
[Music]